ellis yeux de la crise sanitaire à deux
ans de la présidentielle après les
municipales le gouvernement doit-il être
remanié est ce nécessaire quel intérêt
et pour qu'ils y at il des noms qui font
consensus et sera l'objet
c'est plutôt l'objet de notre face à
face ce soir pour en parler
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
alexis poulain cofondateur du monde
moderne bonsoir alexis poulain à ses
côtés francis palombie président de la
confédération des commerçants
ex-candidat l'arrêt main aux
législatives 2010 est en lozère bonsoir
à vos skis francis palombes merci d'être
avec nous alors avant de commencer à
discuter 1 messieurs voici ce sondage
instructif un étude aux hawks apparu il
y a quatre jours à peine une majorité de
français souhaite un remaniement 64% et
surtout un changement de politique c'est
pas étonnant alexis pour l'un c'est
votre souhait aussi oui c'est pas
étonnant enfin on peut voir que ça fait
quand même longtemps qu'il ya une
contestation profonde que ce soit celle
pour la réforme des retraites
l'assurance chômage les manifestations
des gilet jaune maintenant ces
manifestations la classe matters contre
le racisme et les violences policières
ça fait longtemps que le gouvernement d'
emmanuel macron en fait pose problème à
nombreux français parce qu'il est dans
la volonté de ne pas écouter de ne pas
dialoguer malgré ces annonces un ou une
dit toujours qu'il est dans le dialogue
il organisait un grand débat mais
c'était sa parole qui était mise en
scène par la pâle échanges en fait qu'il
pouvait y avoir donc je crois qu'il ya
une vraie fatigue de ce gouvernement
mais à partir du moment où c'est lui qui
choisit on ne peut pas attendre
grand-chose déjà quand on voit la note
de gilles legendre auquel vous faisait
référence
on voit quoi un jeu en fête d'enfant
gâté qui s'amuse à changer de poste au
sein d'un gouvernement a essayé de
monter de monter en grade et pourquoi
parce que quand emmanuel macron créé la
république en marche ce n'est pas un
parti ça n'existe pas donc il réunit en
fait des gens issus de la société civile
qui n'ont pas de carrière politique ou
bien des ambitieux des carriéristes de
la politique qui eux sont prêts à tout
prêt à trahir leur parti c'est le cas
dans
un berger par exemple prêt à toutes les
concessions possibles pour monter
toujours monter et qui font leur auto
promotion c'est le cas de laëtitia via
qui voit là à d'abord une fois élu
député pour principe de vérifier sa
fiche wikipédia de faire sa pub c'est le
cas de marianne schiappa qui maintenant
claironne sur tous les plateaux qu'elle
veut plus surtout quand on pense elle ne
veut pas être premier ministre non c'est
encore trop tôt mais elle entend bien
durer longtemps dans la carrière
politique donc ces affairistes ces
carriéristes
ils sont entre eux ils font sur des
petits bouts de papier leur gouvernement
idéal ça va pas changer la vie des
français ça n'a pas changé les
politiques d'égalité et ça ne va pas
plus loin
francis palombe est important vous que
ça change son gouvernement aux
finalement ça va pas changer grand chose
comme nous le dit entre les lignes lexsi
poulain puisque par définition emmanuel
macron voilà va faire une forme de
changement cosmétique entre ses troupes
vous souhaitez vous en tout cas voir des
nouvelles têtes écoutez moi je vais me
prononcer différemment que monsieur
poulet j'ai écouté avec beaucoup
d'attention salue ce soir très heureux
d'être interviewés en même temps que lui
bien évidemment moi je suis un
représentant professionnel je suis en
quelque sorte un syndicat professionnel
qui rassemble des fédérations
professionnelles de branche
essentiellement des très petits
commerçants de moins de onze salariés et
qui sont confrontées vous le savez
depuis plusieurs mois à une crise
profonde et ils ont été très affectés
ils sont arrivés au moment où nous
aurons un virus est arrivé
eh bien les entreprises pour beaucoup
les très petites étaient déjà épuisés et
puise économiquement donc de ce plat est
arrivée la crise de comics 19 et je le
dois de faire le point de la situation
tu rentre directement économique par
rapport aux commerces aux commerçants et
très petites entreprises le pouvoir face
à la situation
le ministre de l'économie
bruno le maire et des membres du
gouvernement comme le ministère du
travail et d'autres ont pris la
situation en main et ont voulu à tout
prix éviter des sept et onze ans voulu
éviter que le commerce c'est cool ça
aurait peut être le cas pas de recette
pas de charge pas de shark pas de
recette
ça a été le mot m lumineuse bruno le
maire a peut-être offert bon job francis
pralong dit ben moi personnellement je
constate et je suis pas là pour
valoriser plus qu'un autre en politique
je suis pas un homme politique vous avez
rappelé quelque chose me concernant mais
qui remonte à quelques années maintenant
et j'ai bien compris que un syndicat
professionnel ne pouvait pas être
politisée sinon il doit démissionner
sinon je dois me retirer de mon poste
demande un peu ma démission
non je dis que bruno le maire je
souhaite qu'il reste aux manettes de
l'économie parce que par rapport aux
entreprises
il a un réalisme il a un pragmatisme et
hilare jugement fort il ne veut pas de
faillite sous son ministère
il a dit hey les premières réunions de
crise auxquels j'ai assistés versée à
toutes les réunions
je n'ai pas toujours été d'accord avec
le pouvoir j'ai demandé plus pour les
très petites entreprises et je
demanderai encore davantage je demande à
l'heure d'aujourd'hui
malgré le déconfinement qu'on continue à
soutenir gétaz d'y assister à soutenir
les entreprises tpe moins de onze ou 100
salariés sont fragiles respecter mais
qui constitue en termes de nombre par
rapport au commerce en général 98%
donc pas de complexe nous devons
continuer les centres villes doivent se
revitaliser ce gouvernement ont mis en
place un ministère de la cohésion des
territoires
là je suis particulièrement favorable et
je travaille
harris et ministère
pour améliorer améliorer revitaliser je
suis en train de porter une pétition les
importantes contre amazon parce que
c'est un scandale de laisser se
développer des jantes repos amazon qui
vont tuer le commerce de proximité et le
commerce de périphérie également voyez
que il y à des chutes on à remettre mon
prix d'or comme c'est un débat et
pardonnez-moi francis pas non diront on
comprend que face à espalion be a vu ses
fonctions juges et c'est bien normal
dans le sous la forme du prisme de cette
gestion économique de la crise du duc au
vide mais c'est justement le point lexsi
poulain tout ce gouvernement va être
jugé à l'aune de cette crise sanitaire
qu'on vient de vivre sachant qu'il ya
une commission d' enquête sur cette
gestion il ya beaucoup de ministres qui
sont mis en cause aujourd'hui il faut
faire table rase du passé en quelque
sorte c'est ça l'intérêt des manuels
macron aujourd'hui de tourner la page de
cette crise sanitaire
mais son intérêt il est surtout de
sauver son quinquennat parce qu'il reste
à sauver parce que oui monsieur
palombière raison les petites
entreprises les tpe pme ce sont le
poumon de l'emploi dans ce pays
et heureusement qu'on a des aides et
qu'on les aide mais il faut aller plus
loin il faut que les bailleurs jouent le
jeu que les banques jouent le jeu qu'on
évite massivement les faillites mais
pourquoi on en arrive là pour qu'on en
arrive là parce que la crise sanitaire
n'a pas été géré parce qu'au moment où
on aurait pu choisir d'avoir des masques
massivement au moment où il le fallait
on n'en a pas eu
parce qu'au moment où il y aurait fallu
testé massivement on n'a pas testé et
aujourd'hui encore libérant nous dit
finalement frappe à 700000 thèse par
semaine parce que le virus ne circule
plus trop donc la gestion sanitaire a
été calamiteuse calamiteuse et on s'est
retrouvé avec un film évidemment bien
sûr et on s'est retrouvé avec un
confinement qui va être la
catastrophique en terme économique donc
de a à z que ce soit emmanuel macron son
gouvernement la gestion a été
catastrophique qu'on ne nous dise pas le
contraire nous en a nous en vivons
aujourd'hui le problème est alors ils
vont faire ce qu'ils peuvent pour sauver
leur image publique pour sauver leur
poste et pour sauver ce qui peuvent
sauver mais on est dans le mur parce que
les mauvais choix ont été faits par les
gens aux commandes
aucun pays au monde n'a eu sa ministre
de la santé qui a démissionné pour faire
une campagne politique
aucun pays au monde a menti sur les
masques aucun pays au monde à
tardé à mettre en place le confinement
ou à faire les clusters de manière
beaucoup plus strictes pour éviter que
le virus ne se répande sur le territoire
donc qu'on arrête avec cette légende de
faire croire que la gestion de crise a
été correcte elle est très créative
critique avec cette poule 1 mais tout de
même pardonnez moi ça ce que j'avance or
dans le débat excusez moi il ya cette
suite du sondage que je voulais vous
montrer un vous le savez pas de
changement de premier ministre pour les
français deux français sur trois 65%
voudrait bien qu edouard philippe reste
à matignon
ça vous étonne safran 6e palumbi
essayons de faire des réponses courtes
pour se laisser la parole parce qu'on
arrive à la fin de ce débat alors c'est
vrai qu'on critique beaucoup la gestion
lectrices vous à part du gouvernement
mais dans le fond edouard philippe a
plutôt pris des galons lors de cette
crise ducobu 19 contrairement emmanuel
macron bon ce n'est pas de ma part je
veux non parce que je n'ai pas le droit
de juger qui que ce soit mais c'est vrai
que edouard philippe est resté toujours
très réservé très sobre pendant ses
discours il n'a pas vendu la peau de
l'ours avant de l'avoir tué comme on dit
suivant une expression en gaine
française c'est vrai que il a expliqué
beaucoup alors je pense que les français
ayant très peur parce que nous avons eu
peur pour notre santé nous avons eu peur
pour nos proches nous avons eu peur de
perdre la vie et ses barrières c'est
pour cette raison que le déconfinement
boîte être assujetti à une poursuite des
règles malgré que on est tiraillé avec
le souci est la volonté que ça ceux des
consignes vraiment et que les
entreprises repartent
imaginez les restaurants c'est
catastrophique pour eux j'ai deux
fédérations professionnelles qu'il y a
qui parle de restauration alors comme
pour les voyez vous avez la position non
pas d'un syndicaliste du commerce est
bien évidemment
pour un syndicaliste du commerce il faut
sauver sur le plan économique les
entreprises
moi vous savez ici dans une prochaine
interview sur le plateau que nous avons
eu 50 100 200 sites au sein de la
confédération des commerçants de france
je serais vraiment très affecté triste
vraiment heureux et on le serait
évidemment pour ces entreprises alexis
poulain le mot de la fin sur voie ce
bénéfique quand même des douars fini que
peut faire emmanuel macron est-ce qu'il
a intérêt à se débarrasser de ce premier
ministre populaire qui pourrait
peut-être se présenter contre lui en
2022 oui ça reste clairement aujourd'hui
une grande question qui sera qui
pourrait être le candidat de la droite
face à emmanuel macron s'il se
représentait ce qui n'est pas sûr mais
one 2022 est évidemment edouard philippe
paré comme très légitime il a été celui
qui a paru le plus compétent que dans
cette crise le plus le sobre
effectivement et ne plus haïr l'écoutent
vous aviez en face de lui un président
qui était totalement déconnecté qui
parlait d'une guerre qui parlait de
chevaucher le tigre qui faisait des
apparitions lunaire on ne comprenait pas
vraiment ce qu'il voulait dire qu'il
n'utilisait pas les mots et lui arrivait
avec les professionnels de la santé avec
les ministres pour expliquer qu'elle est
elle planqué qu'est ce qu'il pouvait
faire
donc de loin c'est lui qui est apparu le
plus compétent est celui en charge en
commandes de cette crise donc il a été
celui qui a bénéficié du meilleur de la
meilleure image
maintenant est-ce que c'est mieux pour
lui de rester et de continuer dans ce
quinquennat étrange qu'est celui d'
emmanuel macron ou bien de se retirer
s'il est élu au havre et de préparer de
là bas ce qui sera sa candidature pour
2022 s'il souhaite se présenter ça reste
une stratégie politique personnelle qui
sera la sienne on est dans la cinquième
donc c'est une stratégie de personnes
avant de l'idée mais la question mérite
d'être posée et on la suivra évidemment
avec vous merci beaucoup à tous les deux
avec six poulains francis palombes i